Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to Melody
from Missouri? Melody from Missouri. Welcome
to the program. You've been on before,
right? Or am I not remembering correctly?
Speaker 2: Yes. I'm the one who
spoke about the drug controversy.
Speaker 1: I'm the drinking.
That's right. Welcome.
Speaker 2: Hello. So my partner is trans, and with
all these anti-trans sentiments going around and
Missouri being one of us, there's actually a
protest in Jeff City today. Where do you think
it would be safest to go with? It's in the South.
My partner has health issues and we need to move
somewhere warm. And oh, man, I'm kind of like all
these southern, maybe south west, I don't know.
But we're we're kind of lost as to what to do.
Speaker 1: So there's a couple different ways to
go about this. And, you know, it's really this has
to be your choice. But if you said, I want to be
in the South, but somewhere that is kind of like
safer for trans people, I guess we would say. You
know, one of the things there's there's a couple
of things to consider. One is what laws have been
passed regarding everything from trans bathrooms
to school stuff, if it's relevant to you, etc..
So. So like one is like what is the legislation?
And then the other thing is culturally what's
going on. And that really varies way more within
states. It can vary significantly. So like for
example, in Miami, my sense is that Miami itself
and to some degree probably Miami Beach culturally
are very trans friendly. That being said, there
are state level Florida laws that you may see and
say that I don't like. So I'm not up on all of
these details in order to be able to say, hey,
you know, here's here's where you should go. But
I think there's a couple of different things to
look at, which include cultural questions. When
there's kids involved, it's educational and other
things as well as what are the laws that the
states have passed with regard to these issues?
Speaker 2: And we're looking at something
like New Mexico or Arizona, possibly there's
a job I couldn't transfer to. But yeah.
Speaker 1: Arizona's interesting. Arizona's
interesting because the state has become much
more blue, even though there's a lot of crazy
people there, as evidenced by the fact that that
Kari Lake almost won. But there's parts of it that
are correct, correct me if I'm wrong, don't hold
me to this. But like I think Tucson, for example,
is becoming quite a left leaning city. And I've
spent some time down there and really enjoyed
it. So you've really got to look at the details.
Speaker 2: Well, we're kind of in a blue spot in
a red state right now, or Kansas City.
So we're which we've got lots of gay
friendly and trans friendly places that we
go to. But you look at Missouri at large,
and it's kind of getting it from saying it's.
Speaker 1: The state versus local and then the
culture versus law thing. Yeah. Listen, I'm sure
you will end up making the best decision for your
family, but I know it's a tough situation.
Speaker 2: Thank you so much.
Speaker 1: All right, Melody from
Missouri, great to hear from you